hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
leak code 66 plus one we are given a
non-empty array of decimal digits
and so by decimal they basically mean
every digit is gonna be from 0
to 9 right that's decimals any digit
between 0 and 9
and this array of digits is supposed to
represent a
non-negative integer and our job is just
to increment this integer by one so it
seems pretty straightforward right
and they basically tell us that the
digit is stored such that the most
significant digit is on the left side
basically how you would assume that an
integer would be and we can assume that
the integer does not contain
any leading zeros which is pretty
intuitive right so for example let's
take a look at this
this is an array one two three
so this array represents the number 123.
we want to increment this by one how
easy is that well obviously we'd start
at the right side
right and then increment this digit by
one so
three plus one is of course four right
so we change
the three into a four therefore this 123
becomes 124
and then the output array becomes one
two four
second example is pretty similar this
represents
4 321 increment the
first the right hand digit by one so
basically change it into a two
and then that's the output array so that
seems really really easy doesn't it
but it's a little bit misleading they
don't show you one
case that will basically change these
two examples
into difficult examples let's say that
our array was this
let's say this was our input array right
and remember what we're trying to do
here right we're just trying to add
a single number so when i draw it like
this it becomes a little more obvious of
what exactly we're going to end up doing
we're going to add 1
right so we're going to add 1 to this 9
right so 9 plus 1
becomes 10 right so can we change this
digit to a 10 if we did that we would
end up with 9
9 10 right and that represents the
integer
9910 well when you add 1 to 999
it definitely doesn't become 9 000 so we
did something wrong right we forgot one
thing
remember back to your elementary school
math right nine plus
one is ten right but we know that
there's a carry so nine plus one
becomes zero and we take a one and
carry it over here right so that's what
the algorithm is it's basically adding
keeping track of this carry so again
we're going to have
nine plus one that's going to end up
being again zero and we're going to have
another
carry over here so again nine plus one
right so now you kind of see
that this is this problem is not just a
single addition it's going to be a
while loop of continuous additions
potentially right if we got an example
such as this one
so again 9 plus 1 becomes 0 and again
we carry a 1 over here but in this case
we ran
out of digits notice that right we ran
out of digits so what are we gonna do
with this last
carry one we're just gonna take it and
add it over here so i know i'm kind of
drawing over the elite code explanation
over here
but hopefully you can see this basically
we got the ex
the answer that we expected right when
you add 999
with one you expect to get a thousand
right
so our output array is actually gonna
have these four
digits zero 0 0 and
1. so this is what our output array is
going to actually end up being
in this example and so basically these
are the main cases we have to go through
right if you have if you have a 9
already here it's not going to turn into
a 10 it's going to turn into a 0 and if
we
ran out of digits but we still had a
carry we're basically going to be
appending that carry
to our integer array but notice how we
are traversing the array in reverse
order what i'm going to do though is i'm
actually going to reverse the entire
array and then so basically i'm going to
turn it into 3
2 1 so that we can start at the
beginning when we add our digit 1
to this and then at the end i'm going to
take the
array and then reverse it again so that
we can get it back into the format that
we want
then we can return the the array in that
correct
format so with that being said this is a
this is you know pretty self-explanatory
that this is an uh linear algorithm
because we're having to iterate through
the entire input array which is going to
be size
n so the overall time complexity of this
is going to be big o of
n we're not really needing any extra
memory other than the input array
so the memory complexity is just going
to be big o of 1.
that being said let's jump into the code
it's not too bad just a couple edge
cases we have to worry about
so like i said we're going to first
reverse this
integer array and we can do that in
python just like this pretty simple
and i'm gonna keep track of two
variables i'm gonna keep track of the
carry and i'm gonna call that just one
because i'm bad at naming things
and we're also gonna have one other
variable i
for the index of the position of digits
that we're currently at so
one i'm going to initialize to the value
one because remember we do have to at
least
add a single one to this digit
i i'm going to initialize at zero just
at the beginning of the digits
array so we are going to continue to
iterate through
digits while while our one digit
is equal to one and we can basically
just
you know say this as the condition now
it's possible that our
i could be incremented so much that it
becomes out of bounds so one thing we're
going to check is that while i
is at least in bounds and the else case
is going to be if the
i goes out of bounds so if the i is
still in bounds then we're going to be
incrementing of course right
but there's one case that we do have to
handle one special case what if
digits at position i is equal to nine
that's the special case right that's the
case where we get our
carry integer so if this is equal to
nine
one is going to stay as the value one
right and we're guaranteed that one is
right now one like i guess i should have
named this something different but this
because this is gonna be the value one
if our loop is executing at
all so this is gonna remain one so we
don't have we don't actually have to
write that
but as we add one to this digits of i is
gonna be
reset back down to zero but if
we're not dealing with this special case
meaning if the digit is not nine
then we can ordinarily just increment it
by one right so
otherwise we're just gonna increment
this by one and if this was not
nine that means we're not going to have
a carry anymore right so we can take
this
one and then change it into a zero
because we don't have a carry anymore we
don't have to continue adding anything
we can take this back down to zero
now the else condition is when we go out
of bounds right that means we reach the
end there's no more digits to add on to
anymore but we still have a one value
what are we going to do in that case
well
in that case we're just going to take
digits and then append one to it right
because
we're adding a new digit into this
digits array right
and also since you know we don't have a
carry anymore
that means we can take our one and now
reset it again back down to zero right
this is going to terminate our while
loop which makes sense right if we
appended a one
that means we don't have any more to add
on to our digits array
and the one thing you don't want to
forget with while loops is to make sure
you increment your
index so i'm going to make sure to do
that regardless of which
if condition executes we're going to be
incrementing i
and last but not least we're going to be
returning our digits array but remember
how i reversed it at the beginning
so we're going to undo that reverse and
reverse it again
so that we have it in the correct format
that they wanted
and to be honest you probably don't need
to reverse this
you could just traverse the array in
reverse order if you wanted to but i'm
really lazy and i don't like writing
that code i like going from left to
right
so i just wanted to reverse this so this
is the entire code it's not too bad when
you make sure you handle the edge case
of nine
and you make sure you keep track of the
what value the carry happens to be
whether it's zero
or one so other than that i hope that
this was helpful
if it was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon thanks for watching
you